we're just on a rescue boat and that's
coming back from Sanibel Island Sanibel
Island is a Barrier Island just off the
coast of Southwest Florida it's home
usually to around 6 500 people I'll just
spin you around this is the usual way
into the island this is the bridge the
causeway that takes you from Mainland
Florida to Sanibel but you can see here
parts of that bridge completely taken
away washed away by the storm surge no
longer passable and that's why
the rescue attempts for the people who
remained on Sanibel Island and we're
told there may have been hundreds of
people who stayed on the island as
hurricane Ian was hitting those rescues
are taking place
um by boat and you can see some of the
people on this boat are people who who
have just been rescued and they've been
through an unimaginable trauma really
they were there as the water began to
rise one gentleman's just described it
to me as he looked out of the window and
it was like the sea was on the other
side of his window he saw
fishes and debris and eventually that
water started to come into his house and
they had to get up to the second and the
third story of their house in order to
survive other people know of people
sadly on the island losing their lives
and it really is
a scene of complete Devastation that
they're describing it one lady explained
it as like a bomb went off she said it
was literally like Armageddon had
happened there so clearly the immediate
concern is getting people who have
survived off Sanibel Island the
long-term plan will clearly be to
restore power to the island to begin the
cleanup but some people here who have
been rescued say they're not sure
whether Sanibel Island can ever be
restored to what it was